a pro-democracy protest in Hong Kong has
been disrupted by counter demonstrators
waving Chinese flags the sit-in at a
shopping mall in the Chinese territory
became the scene of violent clashes when
pro-beijing activists confronted the
demonstrators this is just one of
several protests planned for today on
Kong is in its fourth month of
pro-democracy demonstrations they were
initially launched to oppose a
controversial extradition bill but have
since widened to demand free elections
in the specially administered territory
ldw correspondent cherry Chan is in Hong
Kong and she joins us now for the latest
so cherry we understand you are near the
shopping mall where those clashes have
been taking place what have you been
seeing so there are a lot of
confrontations between police supporters
and promote recei protesters and first
of all they were all in the shopping
mall and then they had some verbal
confrontations with each other and then
clashes broke out and then riot police
arrived and they actually have arrested
several pro-democracy protesters well
Chery we have been seeing clashes
between the pro-democracy protesters and
police over the last several weeks but
now these violent clashes between
protomatter protesters and pro-beijing
supporters seems to be a new escalation
is it
[Applause]
actually this is not really a new
escalation and confrontations and
conflicts between the two groups have
always exist but then they don't always
appear in the same occasion so we don't
see a lot of pictures where they clash
of each other or have arguments but
today because the pro-democracy
protesters they knew that this
pro-beijing supporters would be in this
shopping mall so they planned to come
here to have counter protests and show
their support for the protesters and
that's why they the two groups meet here
today and clashes broke out
well the pro-democracy protestors had
said that they intended to keep the
demonstrations peaceful so what sparked
the violence
[Applause]
right so they have always planted it to
be peaceful but then de but then
whenever they see pro-beijing supporters
is inevitable that they will clash with
each other because when they post a
political views thank you thank you and
so you can see that the pro-democracy
protesters they are really trying to get
international attention well cherry yes
indeed and where you are is not the only
location where protests will be taking
place in Hong Kong what else is going on
in the city today and today they are
several different protests in different
shopping malls in different districts
they they are also shopping protests in
other parks as well but actually a
during this weekend the biggest protest
is tomorrow the Sunday protest actually
and yesterday when we were on the street
with the protesters we also hear them
calling everyone to join the protest
tomorrow also the protest has been
banned tomorrow by the police but then
these protesters days all they still
said that they will go on the street
anyway did a with cherry Chan reporting
for us from Hong Kong thank you so much